c'est la nature de son travail en
janvier dion croiser des dizaines de
personnes tous les jours et touché des
enveloppes qui ont déjà été manipulé par
d'autres avec la pandémie de coronavirus
le jeune livreur prend des précautions
supplémentaires juste un peu un peu
parano montgiscard d'un peu mieux
contact bonjour au revoir je me lave les
matches chaque fois et on fait attention
son attention est de retour à son
véhicule il désinfecte le volant c'est
comme ça après chaque livraison de
nombreux employés de postes canada nous
ont écrit pour partager leurs
inquiétudes
absence de désinfectant dans les
comptoirs postaux travaillent à
proximité d'autres employés dans les
centres de tri plusieurs juges que
l'employeur ne prend pas la menace assez
au sérieux les conditions idéales noms
ne sont pas l'os et c'est parfait ça ce
repos demain matin le syndicat estime
qu'il ya place à l'amélioration mais
souligne que l'employeur a tout de même
pris certaines mesures
les facteurs qui livrent des colis ne
seront plus tenus de faire signer les
clients question de limiter les contacts
directs
il ya plus des changes de matériel
informatique donc le look chic et
utilisés par les facteurs face signé
entre autres plus changeantes le client
puis le nom facteurs et factrices alors
que plusieurs restaurants ont décidé de
fermer leur salle à manger
les livreurs de nourriture s'attendent à
servir plus de clients que d'habitude
jusque vers les commandements tu es plus
jointe un gain chez st-hubert les
livreurs ont reçu la consigne de se
laver les mains et leur terminal de
paiement
quand ils sont de retour au restaurant
on demande aux gens de pouvoir prépayées
aussi donc quand on arrive on est juste
à donner launch pire
tout est fait en échange d'argent dans
les mains exact c'est soucier recommandé
s'est même dit au centre d'appels que ce
soit aux canards jean grenet accepté
dans d'autres chaînes ce genre de mesure
n'est toujours pas en place et des
livreurs s'en inquiète
ici olivier bachand réseau canada
montréal